Hey youtubers, it's Charlie. This is gonna
be my Agents of SHIELD episode 12 video
and since they made the big announcement about Marvel not going to Comic Con
all explain that too.
There's a lot of stuff going on in the
Marvel Universe right now. Just to start
with the Comic Con stuff, I know that was
a big WTF for everyone.
So here's the deal: James Gunn did a
facebook Q&A like he does every
once in a while
when someone asked him if he was going to San Diego Comic Con and he replied
'I don't think that Marvel's going so
I'm probably not going either, I'm not really sure'
So everyone was kinda like 'Wait, what? Did he just say Marvel is it going to Comic Con,
that's kind of a big deal.' Cut forward to
like another day or so
and he was like 'No, I wasn't lying to the
fans, I'm a pretty sure Marvel's not going'
That's why most of the actual news
reporters in Hollywood right now
are reporting that Marvel isn't going to
Comic Con.
They haven't made it official, Marvel isn't
going to say anything about this definitively
like, they'll either show up or they won't, but they're probably not going to do a big Hall H panel
Just add a little bit more of context: Comic Con was moved way up to the beginning of July this year
they have Ant-Man coming out like a
couple weeks after that, so
by the time Comic Con hits, they'll have
already spent most to their marketing
budget on the movie so there's
there's really no point in them
marketing the movie at Comic Con they
don't gain anything from it.
Plus, they already did their big phase three
panel earlier this year where they announced
all the movies that are coming out in
the next 4-5 years so they don't need to
do that again, they've already done that.
On top of that, because Marvel is Disney, Disney owns D23
they might be doing some presentations
at D23 this year.
That doesn't mean that Marvel is never
gonna do a Hall H at Comic Con.
It just means that they're almost most
powerful enough,
like they almost have enough of a
marketing machine that they don't need
Comi Con, like they had their
own conventions that they can do this at.
I think it's actually a really good idea,
it certainly make my weekend at
Comic Con a lot easier
Marvel, as a studio, does not benefit as
much from Comic Con
as other studios do, so it just doesn't
make as much sense for them to spend
a ton of money if they're not going to
be promoting anything specific.
I'll post more updates about Marvel Comic
Con stuff in the future it they
release any official updates but don't worry, it's not gonna be a huge deal.
So onto Agents of SHIELD,
careful for spoilers from the episode if you
haven't seen it yet. If you guys didn't
recognize him, Eddie McClintock,
was the Kree soldier in this episode,
so I'm gonna explain him first in what he means about
the TV universe because it's kinda
Guardians crossover but not really. Like
they say some very specific things in
the episode that made it seem like
they're not going to do something like
this again.
His name in the episode was Vin-Tak,
that is not a character from the comics
but it is a sign that Marvel is slowly
bringing cosmic stories and Earth-based stories together.
As you can imagine this is a road map to
the end of phase 3
and Avengers: Infinity War where the
Avengers will have a cosmic story
whereas right now they're having
mostly Earth-based stories. As Sif
said at the end of the episode 'I'm going
to take him back to Hala, his home planet,
they won't bother you again'. That
probably means we won't be seeing a
whole lot of other Kree
on Agents of SHIELD. Coulson said 'don't
worry I'll track down the rest of these Diviners',
so the rest of this season is gonna be
tracking down
all the other Inhumans. Obviously the
teaser for the next episode implies
we're gonna meet a whole bunch of
them.
Maybe not love them, but definitely most
of them. So it's a little bit of them
winking at the audience, it's like
'yes this is going on and outer space,
cosmic things, you know
"tides of the universe" as Sif said are
influencing what's happening on Earth'
but they're not gonna be happening on
earth all the time. And yes the Bobby-Mack stuff,
the secret planning,
probably Secret Warriors from the comics.
I don't think it's Secret Avengers, I think
that'll happen like after Captain
America: Civil War.
That's part of my top five moments so don't worry, I'll totally explain it. So top five moments:
number 5: welcome back Sif. They buried
the lead a little bit but Sif
was following Vin-Tak to Earth, to keep
him from taking the Diviners,
or at least trying to find out what it
was he was looking for. She kept saying
the word 'Kava'
that is the Kree word for 'keys'. They ended up going back to the original dig site
where they found the Diviners in the first episode. Remember where Whitehall had that case.
So this episode is a direct link to that
flashback to the Agent Carter flashback in episode one
I always give the writers a giant high-five when they're able to tie the arc
back to big WTF moments in the first
couple episodes.
Also some the funniest moments, some of the funniest jokes
were Agent May talking to Sif about
stuff that she couldn't remember.
Like Thor. 'I don't know why but this name
makes me smile' and then you see Agent
May just smile herself and go, 'I know exactly why she's smiling',
'Odin? Yeah you totally met Odin,
you guys are bros'. I cheered a little bit
when she said that because remember
Loki has been posing as Odin since
the end of Dark World.
So if he set Sif on this mission to find
the Diviners,
it was actually Loki sending her on
the mission. We will definitely talk more
about what's going on with Loki in Asgard because it'll tie in with Avengers: Age of Ultron and
Thor: Ragnarok, but that's
not gonna happen for a while.
so at a tad chrome we'll come back to
that later don't worry. Onto number 4:
Bobby and Mack tease a new secret
organization inside SHIELD.
Probably Secret Warriors. I was really
happy the added a lot of context to this
secret Bobby-Mack plot. The language she
used is very important she said 'remember
what happened when we found out our
friends were HYDRA?'
and then Mack said 'we are not HYDRA'. That implies that whenever shadow
organization that they have running
is not bad, they're not evil. For those that
haven't read the comics
there are many secret organizations
inside SHIELD. There's
SWORD, although technically that's not a secret that's kinda like a cosmic-space based
version of SHIELD,
I don't think that that's what they're
doing. There's also Secret Warriors which is
like a big comic book line and then there's
Secret Avengers.
All those things kinda tie in around
like the Secret Invasion
Dark Reign era of the comic books. What
I think is going on
what I think they're doing is Secret
Warriors just because the show
runners would not stop talking about
Secret Warriors last year.
Like they were huge fans of that story line
in the comics and Daisy Johnson, the
character from the comics
that Skye is and that they turned her into
the Inhuman, she is part at the Secret
Warriors team.
If you guys have a Marvel Unlimited
subscription you can totally read that Secret Warrios
storyline for free, so check it out. Onto
number 3: everyone figures out that Skye
is one of the Inhumans I'm so happy they
didn't drag this reveal out.
Nothing is worse than a TV show teasing
us with someone having super awesome powers
and never letting the character have
fun with them. I was a little worried
with the way Skye was acting whenever the show came back, like she in quarantine,
she started to freak out, you want Karnak to come judo-slap her silly.
Get a hold of yourself, you have awesome
powers, have some fun.
Now that the whole team knows about it,
they can deal with it and they can get
there much quicker so
by the end of the season I think Skye
will have a better command her abilities,
she'll be more self-assured.
Now right away half the group is still
freaking out about it, which is a
little frustrating but they'll get over it.
You can look at it as like a minor tease
for Civil War
from the comics but that not what's going on. There was a lot of language
that sounded very Civil War-esque,
like 'these people are freaks', 'no, these people are humans',
'we need to regulate them', 'we need to lock them away'. Civil War in the comic, if you
haven't read it you can also read it on
Marvel Unlimited,
it's all about the idea of superhero
registration.
Captain America: Civil War - the movie - is
going to be different from that.
Onto number 2: meet Vin-Tak, Kree from Hala.
Most of you guys are familiar with the Kree from Guardians of the Galaxy.
Ronan the Accuser was a Kree, but he was part of the Accuser CorpsAccuser Corps
and he was a fanatic. So he's like a crazy
example of the Kree.
There are Kree that are totally normal,
totally nice people.
Vin-Tak explains he's just trying to
help, he's just trying to take the Diviners
so that they can't create more
"monstrosities"
I'll explain that in a second because
that there's a lot of extra context to be
added there.
Eddie McClintock, awesome actor, I'm
totally sad Warehouse 13 got cancelled,
he was a little ridiculous. I mean I like
him when he's playing a little straighter,
he's a great comedic actor. To explain
the monstrosities thing:
so there is like a subform of Inhumans
that are more genetically deformed than others.
They try to prevent that with selective
breeding. Genetic tailoring is really
important idea for the Inhumans.
They practice thousands of years of selective breeding so they can create better Inhumans.
But every once in a while you get like
someone who's really really deformed.
You could look at that as a teaser for
Raina because she is more physically deformed
But the way Vin-Tak use the term in the
episode, he calls them all monstrosities,
so like even Skye who looks,
you know, totally normal is a monstrosity
by his definition.
They do stray a little bit into After School
Special territory when they're like
'okay you're not deform, you're special'. Like in the last episode when The Reader
rescued Raina and he says 'hello
beautiful' he himself is, you know,
obviously a little bit deformed.
I'm not a huge fan when they get really
on the nose with with their morality like this
like yeah, of course everyone is
supposed to be special, we get it.
Really though, my number one WTF awesome moment was when
Vin-Tak explained the Kree-Skrull War
in Terrigenesis.
I've read a lot of videos on the Inhumans,
so I havesome links in the description, but
the Kree-Skrull War was where the
Inhumans story was born out.
Like Stan Lee created and they kinda weaved it into that. The Kree were
trying to create a super race to use as a
weapon against the Skrulls,
obviously the Skurlls kinda exist in the
Fantastic Four universe,
it's a little up in the air as to wether or not Marvel has the rights to use them.
That's why Joss Whedon used the Chitauri in the Avengers film,
otherwise it would've been a Skrull
invasion. Vin-Tak actually spelled it out clearly:
the Kree, at a certain point realized
that, the Inhumans, as a project,
we're going downhill, like they were
gonna result in something really terrible happening
so they just abandoned, they just like
kinda closed up shop,
you know, locked the doors and walked away and the Inhumans were left to themselves.
That was thousands of years ago, so Attilan like, you know, the royal family - Black Bolt -
they all arose out of an independent
society that evolved on their own.
So the Kree today don't have a whole
lot of interaction with the Inhumans.
And yes, Attilan is out there, they just haven't introduced in the film universe.
I will be interested to see if they
mention it by name on the series.
Probably not, I'm not expecting it but
they might. Here's my big question for you guys:
if they could have anymore like cosmic
cameos, like stuff from the Guardians of the Galaxy universe
on the TV show who would you wanna see? Now remember
like they probably not gonna have Chris Pratt or anyone like that but
any, you know, alien races, who do you
wanna see on Agents of SHIELD?
I think the next logical step would for Coulson to make jokes about
talking dogs, like Cosmo,
or Howard the Duck. Just jokes I don't
think there's any way we're gonna see him on the show
Here are some of the bigger Easter Eggs I saw, there was a whole bunch of loaded comments,
loaded dialogue,
it was a lot of fun. Starting off with
for Full Mortal Kombat
So next week, Kevin Tancharoen, he's the
brother of showrunner
Maurissa Tancharoen, is going to be directing. He is the one who started the
Mortal Kombat web series animated series a long, long time ago.
He was gonna do Mortal Kombat reboot
movie but he passed on the project after a while
so Kevin Tancharoen Mortal Kombat to
Mortal Kombat reference in the episode.
When Bobbi and Hunter had that sex scene and he said
'then you turn into a bit of a nightmare'
she actually she got mind-controled, she got
brainwashed in the comics,
the Mockingbird character amd was evil
for a while so she literally turned into
something of a nightmare.
I already explain the Sif-Loki-Odin stuff
but when she says only seven species
across the Nine Realms require nitrogen
to breath, she was talking about
the Badoon, the Brood,
the Dire Wraiths, the Phalanx, the Shi'ar,
the Skrulls. Very clearly Marvel does
not have the film and TV rights
for all those races but most of them,
so it's just a nice
teaser for things that they can always
introduced at some point. I know everyone
really liked the hammer jokes, there were
so many hammer jobs in this episode.
Rspecially the little tiny hammer that
Eddie McClintock was carrying around.
I don't think that he's part of the
Accuser Corps but Kree do have weapons
and armor, the Accuser Corps, that's coded for them, like he said only he could operate it.
Ronan's hammer from Guarding of the Galaxy is a slightly different one,
it's like a little more powerful it's
called the Universal Weapon.
But most of the Accuser Corps have hammers like that.
And huge congratulations to the winner
of my Avengers: Age of Ultron trailer giveaway
It's just a subscription to the
collector core, that's Marvel's Funko Pop!
subscription service. It's the only way
to get the Hulbuster Pop.
Please message me on the back in my
channel so I can get your contact info.
So like, I said I put more links in
description for my videos in the Kree,
Guardians of the Galaxy stuff and the Inhumans.
While you guys wait for next week's episode you can click here to catch up on Agents of SHIELD if you guys are behind,
and you can click here for the last Age of Ultron trailer.
It's starting to het a little bit cooler than the
previous trailers, lots more Ultron and the Vision.
Thank you so much for watching so let's all do thing. I see you guys tonight.